[Music]
psychedelic drugs in my in my personal
view can be an amazing tool for for
gaining insight into one's own mind to
other people's minds to the the
ecosystem and to the universe in general
so that there's a tremendous amount of
insight that that can be can be plumbed
using using these various substances
there's also a lot of risk there as with
most valuable things I mean I've had
friends and family members you know
literally be pushed over the over the
verge of insanity by you know excessive
and poorly thought-out use the use of
psychedelics so that mean it's it's a
great potential benefit and and a great
potential risk and I think it's
generally a terrible thing that these
substances are illegal in most modern
governments because that means that
we're not developing the right set of
cultural institutions to guide people in
really you know productive use use of
these substances I mean I'm in of course
when I was a teenager in first you
psychedelics it was what like in a Pink
Floyd concert or something right it was
all good fun
it didn't go awry it certainly could
have gone awry right so I think the
these substances can give tremendous
insight I would say you can also get
even without a bad trip or some tragedy
you can get a lot of illusory insights
use it using these things also I mean
Terence Mckenna I loved reading his
books he had a lot of deep insights and
how the mind works I never really quite
believed 2012 was the at the end of end
of an era and the beginning of the dawn
of the new age or something right so I
think there's something that can happen
where symbolic insights or metaphorical
insights that are very meaningful in a
certain domain you can access with
psychedelics then when you bring them
back into this logical and empirical
domain where we spend their everyday
lives you don't want to take these
metaphorical and symbolic insides that
let that literally necessarily and many
people can lose sight of that also so
that you know there's a mix of amazing
reward and insight some dangers and then
just the the risk of things that are
meaningful in some sense but illusory
and delusional with respect to the
empirical and logical world I think a
eyes are gonna just have a lot easier in
a lot of ways so psychedelic drugs are
just very very crude instruments I mean
so I mean LSD is sort of a serotonin
mimetic it looks a little bit like some
neurotransmitters it makes weird
patterns appear before your eyes and it
can give you some real and some fake
insights into how your mind works so you
know DMT is a naturally occurring
substance in the brain if you put a
bunch more into your body than the
naturally occurs many very interesting
things are happening in your brain at
that time it can be a challenge to tell
which of them are real insights or sort
of rampant neural circuits generating
meaningless entertaining movies through
it and I think for an AI things can just
be much more carefully engineered and
thought-out
because it's it's not as though these
drugs were designed by you know
brilliant insightful enlightened
scientists to direct the brain in the in
the direction of maximum insight and
creativity you're just sort of tweaking
things almost in a quasi random way then
it's up to you to fish out the valuable
things from from the states of
consciousness you get into but with an
AI that's engineered it's psychedelic
experiences can can also be engineered
and and you can you can make much more
finely tuned modifications to the mind
of the AI then we're able to do with
with the human brain so and I think the
potential from hybridizing a human brain
with an AI in an engineered mind is also
quite quite fascinating right because
then this AI
can read out the state of the human
brain understand the structure of the
brain and mind and again with this kind
of cyborg type experience I think we can
get much finer grained and more
interesting guidance of states of
consciousness and then we can then we
can with with any drugs that that we
that we have right now so I'm I'm very
much looking forward to all the new
states of consciousness we can explore
once we can you know Jack our brains
into the you know the super human mind
cloud and the AI mind matrix and I think
the singularity is often thought of as a
purely technological singularity like
machines will get smaller and faster you
know people's jobs will be able to be
done by by machines AI will have a
higher IQ than people but we should also
be thinking about this as a singularity
of consciousness and the tremendous
flourishing of new and different states
of consciousness that will be created
once we've really mastered you know
biology neuro psychology AI psychology
the creation of you know bio
electronic cyborgs I mean we're going to
be exploring states of consciousness
that go way beyond anything we can
imagine now and way beyond anything that
the very crude psychedelic drugs that
exist allow us access to
[Music]